so let me ask you what you know why'd
you make the comments you made about
Craig right I know in the past he's
claimed that he's Satoshi and he's the
one that owns the Genesis block and you
know I don't know whether he lost the
private key or not why did you see what
you said about Craig right it's well
documented now very well in numerous
sources that his claims are bogus
and he also is behind a competitor to
Bitcoin or he's part of a competitor
Bitcoin called Bitcoin Satoshi vision
which is an outright the fraud as well
and pretty much he's been called at
numerous times he's launched several
lawsuits that are all either lost or in
the process of losing and there he has
no basis whatsoever to make those claims
he's been it's been shown that they
claims are baseless and the way he
thinks and the way he talks the way he
conducts himself is would be kind of if
you're trying to create a character of
somebody who knows nothing about Bitcoin
who is the antithesis of the character
and the vision behind it it would be
someone like Craig right it was he's a
fool I mean the people in the Bitcoin
community think of Craig Wright as a
fool basically as a fool he has no
credibility whatsoever in the Bitcoin
space he's absolutely laughed at and a
year or two from now we won't hear the
name will be forgotten forever
who else has claimed that their Satoshi
outside of him nobody nobody's ever
claimed that's right interesting do you
have any idea yourself is there anybody
in the community when you talk to you so
you know you kind of have an idea this
whole thing who who was or no it's still
something that's unknown it's unknown
and it's better that it's done now tell
me why because if you have a known
person attached to it they become an
attack vector and people will attack
that person and they and so you don't
want that you want you know who invented
gold yeah this is
their goal is different than them
Bitcoin though then cryptocurrency no
well how's uh how's goal created through
what what creates true through the
creation of 13.8 billion years ago the
Big Bang and the universal started
elements collapse and stars exploded
yeah that's the point it's not man-made
you know gold is not man-made
bitcoin is Kryptos man-made it's
slightly different you know it's a I
would argue that inspiration from for
Bitcoin is divine and that it reflects
it reflects an inner divine nature of
humans so it is similar to gold in that
way if you believe that God created
everything including gold and you would
also believe that God created Bitcoin so
you think God created a Bitcoin do you
think God do you think God created gold
I don't think man created gold well do
you think God created man good that is
the agnostic position let's just say
there is a creator yeah so and
everything in creation goes back to the
Creator
that would include I can't say God
created a car Oh maybe but the reason I
say that the reason I say that is make
that position is because the I realize
that it's a it's an interesting position
but it's also yep the effects that
Bitcoin are having on the world are
quite interesting and that is bringing
about a realignment of the way people
think about themselves and about their
economies and about their communities
because for example Bitcoin encourages
people to save money which is different
than encouraging people to spend money
it's like when you know you have I'm
sure that as part of what you are doing
over there your company and you talk to
your employees and things like that
you know one of the ideas you want to
get folks to understand is to not go too
far into debt don't over consume be self
sabor and be your own person we have
inner strength and morals and values and
then those values
are carried over into your work and your
family in your community and so you know
you can't do that with Fiat money
because fiat money is inherently debt
based money and the more you they issue
the worse the economy gets and it's
extremely a poor system whereas gold you
know people who who buy gold and store
gold they have a kind of a different
attitude toward engravings
okay so Bitcoin bitcoin is the same base
technology bitcoin is a savings
technology that changes people in
profound ways they think differently
about their communities about themselves
it has a very positive effect it's a
it's passive resistance you're opting
out of the fiat money system and you're
now saving Bitcoin it's like you would
save gold and you look at the
Millennials on the gen Z and they're
like you know this is actually in a
world with leaders are corrupt and
mentors are not available and the
business establishment is run by people
of dodgy character you know I'm finding
my my inner kind of strength by saving
and achieving individual sovereignty and
I'm doing it through Bitcoin so that's
why I say it has a celestial or divine
quality about it because it makes people
it raises people's consciousness and
raises their character and that's an
important thing that for folks to
understand it's part of the process of
maturing right you know you have to you
have to take responsibility for yourself
you
[Music]